democrats push forward with impeachment
again in the house as republicans argue
over how to respond i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
then visit expressvpn.com to stay
safely anonymous before we get to any of
the news and boy is there a lot of news
today because
a day in 2021 is like 10 years in
regular time basically we are living the
plot of interstellar we'll get to all
the news
in just one second first let's talk
about something that you can do for
yourself save yourself
some money you're spending way too much
money on the telephone bill you are i
know you haven't thought about it
recently
unless you've been listening to this
show but if you have been listening to
the show you know you're spending way
too much on your cell phone bill because
you're paying for unlimited talk and
unlimited text and unlimited data here's
the thing you're not using unlimited
data what you really need
is the program from pure talk usa when
your family switches to pure talk from a
t verizon or t-mobile you could save
over 800 bucks a year
that is real money every single month
right back in your pocket you don't have
to sacrifice coverage pure talk is on
the same network as one of the big
carriers but they will charge you half
that's right no gimmicks no fluff added
to your bills which is why puretalk is
the top rated wireless company
by consumer affairs how about this offer
right now you get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and if you go over on data
usage they're not going to charge you
for it grab your mobile phone dial pound
250 say
ben shapiro when you do you say 50 off
your first month dial pound 2 5 0
say the key word ben shapiro to get
started pure talk usa simply smarter
wireless get the same coverage as the
big cell phone companies but don't
pay the same bills that you would be if
you were with one of those big cell
phone carriers pure talk usa dial pound
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro
saved fifty percent off your first month
and a lot of money down the road okay so
we begin
with the quick update on everything that
is happening in terms of violence and
prosecutions the acting u.s attorney
michael sherman
said yesterday that from the doj that
he's not sure that the federal
government has seen
something like this the wide variety of
crimes that took place during the
capital riots they are apparently
considering sedition charges against
some of the people who broke into
the capital and were going in there to
do bodily harm to members of congress
here was the
acting u.s attorney michael sherwin the
range of criminal conduct is really
i think again unmatched in any type of
scenario that we've seen the fbi or the
doj we're looking at everything from
simple trespass to theft of mail
to theft of digital devices with inside
the capitol
to assault on local officers federal
officers both
outside and inside the capitol to the
theft of potential
national security information or
national defense information to
felony murder and even civil rights
excessive force investigation so just
the gamut
of cases and criminal conduct we're
looking at is really
mind-blowing okay and apparently there's
the possibility
that this is not going to stop before
the inauguration
according to the houston chronicle the
secret service is going to
launch a massive security operation to
protect the biden inauguration
this is being reported actually from the
washington post carol lennog karen's
emerging justin juvenal and nick miroff
they say the secret service and federal
law enforcement agencies are spending
the final days of the trump
administration
bracing for a possible violent assault
against the january 20th inauguration
launching a security mobilization that
will be unlike any in modern u.s history
on wednesday the secret service will
take command of security preparations at
the us capitol and other federal
buildings backed by as many as fifteen
thousand national guard troops thousands
of police and tactical officers
layers of eight foot steel fencing the
high alert security posture is starting
six days earlier than planned in order
to coordinate roles for the fbi national
guard u.s marshals service and a host of
other federal agencies
that will fall under secret service
command one secret service official said
everyone can just rest assured they are
throwing the kitchen sink
at this event now the reality is that
many of the people who would be
interested in engaging in violence
actually would like to engage in
violence with
members of capitol police with members
of the secret service
because they are looking for the image
that of course is not a reason not to
have the security there the security
there should be there
it shouldn't be just there everybody who
is involved in any act of violence and
this has been my consistent standard
for literally my entire life should be
arrested and locked up
and the key thrown away veteran secret
service and homeland security officials
who spoke on the condition of anonymity
to share their worries describe the
level of concern unlike anything in
their careers
threats they fear include a plot by
armed groups to encircle the white house
or u.s capitol
and the inauguration event as well as
the possibility the gunman could stage
coordinated attacks
against less fortified targets in the
city apparently house democrats were
briefed
by the new capitol police leadership on
monday night about threats to the
inauguration
from groups supporting trump the new
security measures they're putting in
place to avoid a repeat of last
wednesday's riot apparently the threats
included promises to execute members of
congress the most dangerous came from a
handful of extremist
groups on tuesday police in the chicago
suburbs arrested a 45 year old named
louis capriati
charging him with making threats to
lawmakers last year in which authorities
say he promised to kill any democrat who
attempted to enter the white house
on inauguration day representative jim
hymes of connecticut said in an
interview the threats are real but will
not stop the transfer of power which of
course
is true and vice president mike pence is
planning on attending the inauguration
president trump of course has said that
he is not going to attend the
inauguration
okay so the chairman meanwhile the the
chairman of the
joint chiefs wrote a letter to members
of the armed forces
telling everybody that biden would
become the 46th president this is
not necessary but the fact that people
even think it's necessary is really sad
obviously the joint chiefs wrote a
letter to everybody in the armed forces
saying the violent riot in washington dc
on january 6 was a direct assault on the
us congress the capitol building our
constitutional process we mourn the
deaths of two capital policemen and
others connected to these unprecedented
events
as service members we must embody the
values and ideals of the nation we
support and defend the constitution
any act to disrupt the constitutional
process is not only against our
traditions values and oath it is against
the law on january 20th in accordance
with the constitution confirmed by the
states and the courts certified by
congress president-elect biden will be
inaugurated
and will become our 46th
commander-in-chief
to our men and women deployed and at
home safeguarding our country stay ready
keep your eyes on the horizon remain
focused on the mission
we honor your continued service and
defense of every american so that is
obviously the the military basically
just making clear to everybody including
the media
guys there's not going to be a coup
attempt here right nothing is happening
here
okay meanwhile democrats are pushing
forward toward impeachment
in the house to hear some updates by the
way on the arrest being made around the
capitol hill rioters you should check
out matt walsh's show today he's going
to be covering this at 1 30 pm eastern
over at dailywire.com meanwhile the big
news of the day of course is the
democrats are pushing toward impeachment
they do have a majority in the house
that will certainly support
impeachment today the real question is
whether republicans are going to support
that effort the impeachment resolution
has only one charge
so that single article of impeachment is
all about incitement
the actual text of the impeachment
resolution
suggests that president trump is
responsible for the riots because he
incited
the riot uh the the the actual text
suggests that he reiterated false claims
that we won the election
uh he willfully made statements that in
context encouraged and forcibly
foreseeably resulted in lawless action
at the capitol such as if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore thus incited by
president trump says the incitement
charge
members of the crowd he had addressed in
an attempt to among other objectives
interfere with the joint session's
solemn constitutional duty to certify
the results of the 2020 presidential
election unlawfully breached and
vandalized the capital
injured and killed law enforcement
personnel menaced members of congress
the vice president and congressional
personnel and engaged in other violent
deadly destructive
and seditious acts trump's conduct on
january 6th this is all in the
incitement
charge that's going to be used as the as
the basis for the impeachment in the
house
followed his prior efforts to subvert
and obstruct the certification of the
results of the 2020 presidential
election those prior efforts included a
phone call on january 2
2021 during which president trump urged
the secretary of state of georgia brad
raffensberger to quote unquote find
enough votes to overturn the georgia
presidential election results and
threatened secretary raffensberger
if he failed to do so in all of this
president trump gravely endangered the
security of the united states and its
institutions of government he threatened
the integrity of the democratic system
interfered with the peaceful transition
of power and imperiled a co-equal branch
of government
he thereby betrayed his trust as
president to the manifest injury of the
people of the united states
says the says the impeachment charge
whereby trump by such conduct has
demonstrated he will remain a threat to
national security democracy and the
constitution if allowed to remain in
office and has acted in a manner grossly
incompatible with self-governance and
the rule of law
trump thus warrants impeachment and
trial removal from office
disqualification to hold and enjoy
any office of honor trust or profit
under the united states okay so that is
the
charge that is being put forth for
impeachment okay so this
requires us to now take a close look at
what exactly are the rationales for
impeachment and what are the rationales
against impeachment
because what we just saw is indeed
unprecedented in modern times
president trump spoke to a crowd of tens
of thousands possibly hundreds of
thousands of people in washington dc
some of those people then went and
invaded the capitol building with
in some cases blood on their mind
clearly people were going in there with
zip ties
there there was actual blood spilled
they were attempting
obviously and first and foremost to
disrupt the constitutional working order
they were going there with lies in mind
right lies about the the
election being stolen lies that the
congress of the united states had the
power to overturn state-certified
electoral results
they were going so what happened on
wednesday as we talked about
all of last week and we'll continue to
talk about was absolutely egregious in
every way the question is whether
this amounts to an impeachable charge
against trump so there's two questions
one
is impeachment warranted for trump and
two is it prudent right so these are two
separate questions they're not quite the
same
the first relies on what your concept of
impeachment is
right and this is a serious question
what exactly is impeachment four so if
you want to say that impeachment is for
high crimes and misdemeanors meaning
that an actual legal
violation has to be found it's gonna be
difficult to impeach trump along those
lines
as we'll get to in just one second if
you say that it is a political remedy
to a political breach by the president
well then impeachment looks
more legitimate but here is the problem
there are some complicating factors
so we're going to get to all of this in
just one second really analyze it we're
going to try and be as dispassionate as
possible
and try to steal man some of the
arguments in favor of impeachment
and not straw man then we're going to
try and suggest what exactly are the
arguments that folks are making
and why exactly are those arguments
flawed if they are flawed we'll get to
that in just one second first
let us talk about your house so right
now look around your house looks pretty
nice right but there's something a
little dingy and off about your house
i'll tell you what it is you haven't
looked at your window coverings right
those window coverings have not been
updated in 15 20 years they're starting
to look dingy the curtains look yucky
and what you really need is to go over
to blinds.com and shop
top quality blinds shades interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping
the experts at blinds.com understand
that window treatments are one of the
household items you just don't think
about they can make an enormous
difference on the look and feel of your
home
you don't need to do a full renovation
by simply changing what's on the windows
you can create a totally different feel
because it changes how light comes into
the home which is a huge thing
go to blinds.com just take a look at all
the options faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades even outdoor shades
if you're nervous about trying them
there's really no reason to be
blinds.com has helped millions of
homeowners through the process plus
they guarantee the perfect fit whether
you do it yourself or have them measure
and install everything
for you we've used blinds.com before
they really do a fantastic fantastic job
go right now
see how much you can save at blinds.com
when you check out online don't forget
to tell them you heard about blinds.com
from the ben shapiro show that helps
them
it helps us rules and restrictions that
may apply check them out at blinds.com
today okay so the really three
rationales
for impeachment and then we'll get to
the three rationales against impeachment
so the three rationales in favor of
impeachment
the first is what democrats are claiming
which is that trump actually committed a
crime
right the incitement charge is the
suggestion that trump committed a crime
and that crime was incitement right that
was the crime of incitement
right that is what the actual article is
it's a one article
charge article one incitement of
insurrection
the constitution provides that the house
of representatives shall have the sole
power of impeachment and that the
president
shall be removed from office on
impeachment for and conviction of
treason
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors
further section 3 of the 14th amendment
to the constitution prohibits any person
who has engaged in insurrection or
rebellion against the united states
from holding any office under the united
states so they're trying to link this
with the 14th amendment the 14th
amendment was specifically written in
the aftermath of the civil war
in order to prevent people who had been
confederate handmaidens
from serving in the government that was
to prevent jefferson davis from coming
back
as a senator the notion that trump falls
under the 14th amendment is an
extraordinary stretch right just legally
speaking he doesn't fall under the 14th
amendment neither is josh halley neither
does ted cruz
that does not amount to an insurrection
uh under the 14th amendment
in his conduct while president of the
united states in violation of his
constitutional oath faithfully to
execute the office of the united states
and to the best of his ability preserve
provide protect defend the constitution
they say that trump engaged in high
crimes and misdemeanors by inciting
violence against the government
of the united states and so ilhan omar
makes the dumb person's case this way
she says that this is like holding a
murderer accountable
i know that some have um likened uh
the the reaction that we are getting
obviously from the president
um and some of you know democrats and
and
and some of uh republicans in in
congress
um to someone saying you know if we if
if we were
to hold a murderer uh or someone who's
committed
violence uh accountable there will be
more
and to me it is um
really the act having
consequences for actions that act as a
deterrent
okay so first of all uh there there is
some grave irony to ilhan omar
who went extraordinarily soft on riots
around the nation talking about holding
murderers accountable because
you just have to hold people accountable
for their violent actions it's also
supremely ironic from melhan omar who
literally wrote a letter
to a judge recommending that a recruit
of isis ought to be let out of prison
early
because that person had been impacted by
their social circumstances so it's
always weird to hear democrats talk
about crime and punishment
in this way at least democrats like
ilhan omar in any case what is the
actual legal standard
so if you're talking about legal
incitement the standards on legal
incitement are really really loose
okay in order to be considered to
responsible for
incitement of violence there is
something the supreme court put in place
in brandenburg versus ohio in 1969 it's
called the brandenburg test
right the brandenburg test was
established to determine when
inflammatory speech intending to
advocate illegal action can be
restricted
in the case of brandenburg versus ohio
is according to cornell law school
a kkk leader gave a speech at a rally to
his fellow klansmen after listing a
number of derogatory racial slurs he
then said quote it's possible there
might have to be some
vengeance taken okay the court found
that this was
not actual the speech has to be directed
to inciting or producing imminent
lawless action like
it has to be pretty clear right you want
to incite lawless action right now
and the speech is likely to incite or
produce such action
so examples of things that are not
actually
applied under the brandon protest would
be hess versus indiana 1973 the supreme
court
said that a an indiana university
protester who said
we will take to the effing street again
the supreme court
said that that was protected under the
brandenburg test because the speech
amounted
to nothing more than advocacy of illegal
action at some indefinite
future time and the court said since
there was no evidence or rational
inference from the import of the
language that his words were intended to
produce or likely to produce imminent
disorder those words could not be
punished by the state on the ground
they had a tendency to lead to violence
in naacp versus claiborne hardware
1982 the supreme court found that a
a person named charles evers threatened
violence against those who refused to
boycott white businesses
the supreme court applied brandenburg
found that the speech was protected they
said strong and effective extemporaneous
rhetoric cannot be
nicely channeled in purely dulcet
phrases an advocate must be free to
stimulate his audience with spontaneous
and emotional appeals for unity and
action in a common cause when such
appeals do not incite lawless action
they must be regarded
as protected speech so the supreme court
has a pretty broad standard and
virtually all lawyers agree
that what trump did does not amount to
legal incitement right you couldn't
charge him in a court of law
with incitement that's that's
specifically true because
again you can argue that trump was
urging imminent action
right he literally said i want you to go
to the capitol building and march with
me
but he also said peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard so
he didn't say i want you to go to the
capitol and invade the capitol he used a
bunch of charged language
it was highly charged i don't think it
was great and none of this is to argue
that what trump has been doing for the
past couple months is appropriate decent
or good
okay but in order to meet the test of
legal incitement which is the crime that
you would want under high crimes and
misdemeanors the test is a little bit
higher
is a little bit higher right that test
is did he
mean to incite imminent lawless action
right that is the brandenburg test
well if he did it would be weird for him
to say that you should peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard
here was president trump saying just
that at the rally the other day
come to demand that congress do the
right thing
and only count the electors who have
been lawfully
slated lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
today we will see whether republicans
stand strong
for integrity okay so
again peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard is not quite the same
thing as i want you to go over there
invade the capitol building
and uh and beat a police officer to
death that doesn't seem like
quite the same thing so in any senate
defense against impeachment obviously
that is going to be trump's defense
is listen if you wanted to impeach me
for all the stuff that i've said since
the
since the election right then you'd have
to find the grounds upon which you could
impeach me
right you can't find those grounds and
to suggest that i
incited the violence as opposed to
raising the temperature is a different
thing now listen
i've had that standard for a very long
time right i've said this a thousand
times on the show
when barack obama said over and over and
over again that the police
were racist across the country that the
policing had a systemically racist
problem that blacks in america were at
existential risk and then a black lives
matter supporter went and shot to death
six dallas police officers in 2016.
i didn't say that obama was responsible
i said that obama was responsible for
increasing the temperature in the
country and that was really
bad but was he responsible for the man
shooting
six police officers no bernie sanders
spent years claiming
that if you didn't back medicare for all
it's because he wanted people to die
that republican attempts to stymie
obamacare were designed at killing
people and then a bernie sanders
supporter went and shot a bunch of
congress members of congress including
steve scalise almost to death
i said at the time bernie sanders was
responsible for raising the temperature
did he deserve to lose his office for
quote-unquote incitement no that's not
the way
any of this works okay so my standard
for incitement has been completely
consistent
across time for democrats and
republicans i cannot say the same for
most of the people in the political
sphere
and again it is worth noting politics is
replete with all sorts
of of i would say violent rhetoric
rhetoric that that exacerbates the
tensions that raises the temperature
rhetoric passionate rhetoric that
that is implicit with with sort of
violent imagery i mean how many times
have you heard a politician say that we
need to fight fight fight fight fight i
mean that's that's republican and
democrat
in fact here's a little montage of
various democrats using some rather
inflammatory language
just over the course of the past couple
of years i
i just don't even know why there aren't
uprisings all over the country and maybe
there will be
people need to start taking to the
streets this is a dictator
you know there needs to be unrest in the
streets for as long as there's unrest in
our lives
enemies of the state show me where it
says that protests are supposed to be
polite
and peaceful do something about your
dad's immigration practices you feckless
when they go low we kick off how do you
resist the temptation to run up and ring
her neck
biggest terror threat in this country
is white men most of them radicalized
right up to the right i thought he
should have punched him in the face i
said even if you lost he insulted your
wife
he came down the escalator and called
mexicans rapism earth he said well what
do you think i should have done so i
think you should punch him in the face
and then gotten out of the race
he would have been a hero i'd like to
punch him in the face
okay so as far as the first rationale
for impeachment which is that trump
committed a crime
it could be very difficult to meet that
test okay so that brings us to the
second
the second argument in favor of
impeachment and this one
is at least more honest right the second
argument in favor of impeachment
is that this was a challenge to the
legislative branch that the
legislative branch of government cannot
abide challenges from the executive
branch of government if the executive
branch of government attacks the
legislature in the way that trump
attacked the legislature rhetorically
speaking
that the legislative branch needs to
fight back particularly if that
culminates
in an actual attack by armed supporters
of that person on the capitol building
right this is strong it's not a criminal
argument it is now a political argument
right saying our sole method of
protecting ourselves against the
executive branch
is for us to strike back with
impeachment this is the angle that's
being taken by liz cheney the number
three
house republican a lot of people very
angry at liz cheney today again
i think the difference is as always my
opinion on this is the differences of
opinion are acceptable within the
republican caucus and within the
democratic caucus
and i think we should we ought to take
the argument at least seriously even if
we decide
at the end that the argument lacks so
here's what liz cheney said she said
she's going to vote to impeach trump
today she says on january
6 a violent mob attacked the united
states capital to obstruct the process
of our democracy
and stop the counting of presidential
electoral votes this insurrection caused
injury death and destruction in the most
sacred space of our republic
much more will become clear in the
coming days and weeks what we know now
is enough
the president of the united states
summoned this mob assembled the mob and
let the flame of this attack
everything that followed was his doing
none of this would have happened without
the president
the president could have immediately and
forcefully intervened to stop the
violence he did not there has never been
a greater betrayal by a president of the
united states of his office and his oath
to the constitution
i will vote to impeach the president
okay so basically the argument here is
not even
criminal incitement right the argument
here is that on a broad sort of causal
level without trump none of this happens
which is very likely true right on a
broad causal level it's true that james
hodgson's in the the congressional
baseball shooter doesn't go and shoot a
bunch of people
uh if if bernie sanders isn't saying
what he's saying it's on a broad causal
level
lots of rhetoric is is you know endemic
to to violence that happens in the
nature of politics
right so the the reality here uh of of
what she's saying which is that this is
a challenge to the legislative branch
that culminated in violence
uh that's an actual argument that's an
argument that i've heard from a lot of
good hearted republicans and a lot of
conservatives who have called for
impeachment here the wall street journal
editorial board made a similar argument
last week
which the legislative branch has to
defend itself and that's that's an
argument worth taking seriously
now what's sort of interesting about the
argument is that the the argument that
trump was making originally is that he
was imputing powers to congress that
congress does not actually have
it's sort of a bizarre situation because
usually when the executive challenges
the legislature
it's to deprive the legislature of
powers that the legislature does have
right usually when you hear presidents
attacking the legislature it's the
do-nothing congress
if you don't do what i want to do then
i'm just going to use the pen and a
phone
the legislature is is uh is a
institution that is not worthy of
respect and so we're just going to take
its authority and use it here in the
executive branch
in this particular case trump was doing
the very odd bizarre and
constitutionally incorrect thing of
suggesting that the legislature the
federal legislature had the power
to actually overturn state electoral
results so he was imputing power to
congress that congress doesn't actually
have
nonetheless the president you know
urging people to go
march on the capitol building uh and
even if not to do violence
uh is a is a unique thing we haven't
really seen that before
is that impeachable i i wonder whether
that's impeachable
again that comes down to whether trump
actually incited
so the the broad causal argument i'm not
sure sustains
all the way through in other words did
trump tell people
i want you so i think that the legal
incitement standard is not just for me a
legal incitement standard i think it's
sort of a moral incitement standard too
when it comes to the issue of causation
you can say that broadly speaking
trump caused everything that followed
but i think that on a moral level
can you say that that trump is
responsible to the extent
that that he wanted people to go invade
the capitol building and attack mike
pence
physically and and harm people uh i
think that is is going to be a bit of a
stretch
so does that mean that it's it's
completely out of bounds
for liz cheney to say what you say i
think it's completely out of bounds i
just think that that her argument
is too strong and proves too much
because you could certainly see a point
in the past or in the future
where the presidency attacks a co-equal
branch of government an extraordinary
language
and as long as he's not urging people to
openly attack that institution
that's still an attack on a co-equal
branch of government that sort of stuff
happens pretty regularly in american
politics
the issue here is that a bunch of fringe
wackos decided that they were going to
invade the capitol building
under those auspices and then finally
we'll get to in just a second the third
the third rationale for impeachment and
the third rationale for impeachment
uh is just pure politics so the first
was something criminal happened i don't
think that's correct
the second was this was a challenge to
the legislative branch's authority i
think there's a lot of truth
to that one but i also think that that's
an argument that applies broadly to a
lot of people in the past so maybe we
should impeach presidents more often
maybe it would be the comeback then the
third is just pure politics which seems
to be
why democrats are doing what they are
doing right here not all democrats i
think some democrats
are you know participating in the first
two standards they think an actual
violation of law happened
some democrats are suggesting that it's
violation of the prerogative of the
legislative branch i get that
but it's hard to look at the actions of
democrats in leadership over the last 48
hours last last week really
and not see an attempt to play politics
we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
your need for life insurance so
it's been a really dismal year really
dismal year and maybe that's got some
dark thoughts percolating in that brain
of yours well while those
thoughts are percolating why not turk it
and why not turn that do something
useful
so for example you need life insurance
god forbid something should happen to
you and your family
is left without any sort of income you
are going to be upset
or you would be upset were you alive
that you had not gotten life insurance
this is why you should go check out
policy genius
right now policy genius makes it easy
for you to compare more than 30 top
insurers all at once
save over 50 in the process there's no
hassle they're licensed experts work for
you not the insurance companies here's
how it works
first you head on over to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price policy genius will
compare policies starting
at as little as a buck a day you might
even be eligible to skip that in-person
medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything soup to nuts that kind of
service has earned policy genius a
five-star rating across over 1 600
reviews
on trustpilot and google so make this
year you finally cross life insurance
off your to-do list get protection for
your loved ones go to policygenius.com
right now and get started
it could say 50 or more by comparing
quotes start the new year with one less
thing to worry about policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice and
extraordinarily important
to get it right okay so as i say there
are three reasons
why impeachment is being pursued one is
that some people think that trump
actually committed
a formal crime i think that that's a
very difficult standard to uphold very
few lawyers would say that it counts as
legal incitement what trump did the
other day
number two is the overall challenge to
the legislative branch i think there is
some legitimacy to the idea that trump
challenged the authority of the
legislative branch who's sending people
to march
on the capitol building i also think
that that has been a long time
move by a variety of presidents this is
just a much more extreme
version of it i mean fdr suggested that
he was going to pack the supreme court
because he didn't like the outcome of
the supreme court if his supporters had
then gone and marched on the supreme
court
it would look like something very
similar so once you separate out the
incitement
issue and you get into the challenge to
the legislative branch
then that looks bad and ugly i'm not
sure that it looks impeachable
i understand the the countervailing
logic by the way which is
the liz cheney logic which is the
legislative branch cannot stand for this
sort of infringement on its authority
and in fact you know i'm kind of happy
to see if the legislative branch wants
to stand up to the executive just on a
broad level
i just my problem is i think it's
partisan but uh if if the legislative
branch wants you far more often stand up
to the executive branch
i think that'd be a welcome development
finally there's the third rationale for
impeachment and this one seems like it
is
it's most cynical it's also probably the
most accurate because we live in a very
cynical time
and that is just pure politics this is
not really about principle so much as it
is
about the pure politics of the situation
the way that you can tell
that there's a lot of truth to this is
the way that the democrats decided that
they wanted to
move forward with the impeachment so the
first thing that they did
is they pushed for mike pence to use the
25th amendment
right they suggested they passed a
resolution trying to push mike pence to
use the 25th amendment now that's
unconstitutional
okay the 25th amendment is an executive
branch remedy for the president
being incompetent it was originally put
into law after woodrow wilson
essentially went brain dead while he was
president of the united states
and his wife edith was essentially
running the country and so
congress the states they decided you
know what we're going to need a solution
to this and that is the cabinet can
declare that the president
is incompetent and then replace him with
the vice president but that is an
executive branch remedy it has to then
be
greenlit by the legislative branch it's
a very complicated process but
it's generally not the legislative
branch threatening that if
the executive branch doesn't do what it
wants then they are going to impeach
that would be the legislative branch
now in now encroaching on the territory
of the of the executive branch right so
it's sort of the reverse of the argument
that was being made a second ago
about why trump needs to be impeached
for violating the prerogatives of the
legislature
so nancy pelosi tried to pass a
resolution suggesting
use of the 25th amendment and mike pence
slapped that down he wrote a letter to
pelosi he said he's not going to invoke
the 25th amendment he said
every american was shocked and saddened
by the attack on our nation's capital
last week
i'm grateful for the leadership you and
other congressional leaders provided in
reconvening congress to complete the
people's business on that very same day
it was a moment that demonstrated to the
american people the unity that is still
possible in congress when it is needed
most
but now with just eight days left in the
president's term you and the democratic
caucus are demanding that the cabinet
and i invoke the 25th amendment
i do not believe that such a course of
action is in the best interest of our
nation or consistent with our
constitution
last week i did not yield to pressure to
exert power beyond my constitutional
authority
to determine the outcome of the election
i will not now yield to efforts in the
house of representatives to play
political games
at a time so serious in the life of our
nation so pence is saying like i can see
the politics here lady like we know
exactly what you're doing
which is right as you know full well the
25th amendment was designed to address
presidential incapacity or disability
just a few months ago when you
introduced legislation to create a 25th
amendment commission you said quote a
president's fitness for office must be
determined by science and fact
he said then we must be very respectful
of not making a judgment on the basis of
a comment or behavior we don't like but
based on a medical decision
madam speaker you were right under our
constitution the 25th amendment is not a
means of punishment or usurpation
invoking the 25th amendment in such
manner would set a terrible precedent
after the horrific event of last week
our administration's energy is directed
to ensuring an orderly
transition the bible says for everything
there's a season a time for every
purpose under heaven a time to heal a
time to build up that time is now
in the midst of a global pandemic
economic hardship for millions of
americans
and the tragic events of january 6th now
is the time for us to come together now
is the time to heal i urge you and every
member of congress to avoid actions that
would further divide and inflame the
passions of the moment
work with us to lower the temperature
and unite our country as we prepare to
inaugurate president-elect biden as the
next president of the united states
i pledge to you that i will continue to
do my part to work in good faith with
the incoming administration to ensure an
orderly transition of power so help me
god
by the way mike pence's behavior during
this whole debacle has been
extraordinary
i mean really really good i mean mike
pence has done what he was
constitutionally supposed to do under
heavy pressure
from trump to violate his constitutional
oath of office
apparently now stories emerging that
trump had said directly to pence
when it when it came to whether he
should count the dually certified
electoral votes
that you can either be a patriot or you
can be a p word see how i say p word
even if it's not a cardi b song
apparently that's that's what trump said
to pence and pence decided actually to
be a patriot which is to do his
constitutional duty
okay but the fact that the democrats
were attempting the 25th amendment
as opposed to impeachment first suggests
that politics were being played here
also suggesting that politics are being
played here that this is a lot about
democratic political game
is who nancy pelosi is now appointing to
be the the
managers the house impeachment managers
so
included among their number eric
swalwell who most recently was seen
screwing chinese spies apparently
uh and and being on the intelligence
committee at the same time so that is
that is good times
uh that that's that's really solid other
people jamie raskin
of maryland is going to serve as the
lead impeachment manager
jamie raskin did indeed in 2016
challenge
10 of 29's uh florida's 29 electoral
votes saying that
they violated florida's prohibition
against dual office holders
so it's interesting that um you know the
the apparent
push by trump to challenge electoral
votes
uh jamie raskin is going to be leading
the way on the impeachment despite the
fact that jamie raskin did the exact
same thing
back in 2016. meanwhile as far as
playing politics
goes the democrats are not stopping in
trump of course their suggestion is that
it's time to expel
members of congress who challenge
electoral votes
so democrats are now pushing that
measure
according to the new york times
progressive house democrats on monday
introduced legislation that would allow
a committee to investigate and
potentially expel republican lawmakers
who had participated in efforts to
subvert the results of the november
election
the legislation would direct the house
ethics committee to investigate and
issue a report on lawmakers who had
sought to overturn the election and
determine if they should face sanction
including removal from the house of
representatives that sounds like playing
politics you don't like what they did so
now you're going to expel them they're
duly elected members of congress
you're going to expel them from the
house of representatives now i don't
like what they did either okay i don't
think the electoral votes should have
been challenged
i don't even think there's a ground for
the challenge of the electoral votes
and this i'm apparently in the minority
when it comes to the house of
representatives where a bunch of
republican house members actually
issued the challenges but just cause i
don't like something doesn't mean that
you get to expel the member
again jamie raskin did the exact same
thing in 2016. i don't think he should
lose
his house seat because of that he should
if he's i mean i don't think she'll hold
the house
based on electoral results but i don't
think she'll be expelled
the democrats attempt to expand the
definition of the 14th amendment to
include challenges to electoral votes
is really really crazy and super
political obviously
cory bush a black lives matter democrat
right i mean that's literally how she
got her start as a black lives matter
activist she said even if it's just a
few
we have to make sure the message is
clear you cannot be a sitting congress
member and incite an insurrection and
work to overturn an election
work to overturn election okay now we
get into like super political territory
because the democrats worked for four
years to overturn the results of the
2016 election
with all of the russian nonsense
democrats refused to accept that trump
had been elected president of the united
states in 2016 in any serious way
okay so like th the this is the third
rationale for impeachment and it seems
like
frankly the most obvious which is the
purely political
and sherrod brown the senator from ohio
he suggested that the
the senate of the united states should
move to expel josh halley under the 14th
amendment
i'm not a big halley fan i think what
hallie did here was really really bad i
thought it was really cynical
i think hallie knew that the election
was not quote unquote stolen i think
halle knew
that there was not sufficient evidence
of voter fraud or voter irregularity to
overturn any electoral results in fact
he said as much
i think that's bad do i think that that
is insurrection under the 14th amendment
to the constitution no not unless you're
a nut
here is a shared brown being a nut the
public humiliation doesn't seem to
matter much
even even some of their allies their um
senator holly's um his sort of mentor
former senator danforth has said that
uh he was speaking well i remember exact
words but that he wished he hadn't
encouraged him to run for the senate
they're
they're hearing that but the senate as a
body needs to take action and i i know
senator mcconnell won't
but we should if he's not going to
resign which of course they won't
they continue to be like trump and take
no responsibility for anything even
though we saw their words we saw the
picture of
of holly um who george will said there's
a huge chasm between his ambition and
his achievement
uh then uh we should take action on
expulsion
okay so again that looks super duper
political so those were the three
rationales in favor of impeachment one
is the super political one is the
challenge to the legislative branch
that's the only one that i think has any
legitimacy at all
and the third is the the incitement
charge which again is legally
specious okay so in a second we're gonna
get to the three cases against
impeachment like why impeachment would
not be the the proper
the proper remedy here we'll get to that
in just one second
first we're trying to take all the
passion out of this right we're trying
to take all the passion and just analyze
first let's talk about the fact that a
lot of dudes out there
losing their hair obviously right male
pattern baldness runs in my family it's
something that freaks me out it's not
something that i want to be a part of
well you need a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care
sexual wellness it's time to write a new
chapter one in which you actually have
hair thanks to science baldness can now
be an
optional thing hymns is helping guys be
the best version of themselves with
licensed medical providers and fda
approved products
to help treat hair loss we're not
talking about snake oil pills or gas
station counter supplements
hymns was created by a dude who knows
some of men's health conversations are
easier online and in person it's easier
to be
discreet and get your medication in mail
no more awkward in-person doctors visits
or long pharmacy lines four hymns
connects you to licensed medical
professionals online that can save you
hours it's completely confidential and
discreet
the answer a few quick questions a
medical professional will review if they
determine it's right for you they can
prescribe you medication to treat hair
loss that is shipped directly to your
door today
hymns is giving you their best offer yet
if you're not happy with their results
after 90 days hymns will give you a full
refund so you got nothing to lose right
now my listeners can get their first
visit absolutely free
go to for hymns.com that is for hims.com
ben prescription products require an
online consultation with a healthcare
provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate restrictions
do apply
see website for full details and
important safety information remember
that's for hims.com
ben okay we're gonna get to the three
cases against impeachment
in just one second first tomorrow night
is a big night for the daily wire for
this company
daily wire makes its grand entrance into
entertainment content we've been talking
for a long time
about culture being upstream of politics
and how republicans conservatives
people who are just not of the left need
to fight the culture war well we are
getting involved
at 7 pm eastern 4 p.m pacific we will
air a virtual premiere of our first
feature film run hide fight
in a special episode of backstage the
premiere will stream live over at daily
wire website mobile and streaming apps
as well as our youtube channel after
tomorrow's event the movie will be
available exclusively to daily wire
members
now please be aware run high fight it's
not really political
right it is intense it is not a leftist
film it is for mature audiences only
okay it's a rated r
film the movie follows a high school
besieged by a quartet of school shooters
when one young girl 17 year old zoe hull
uses her wits and survival skills to
fight back this is not like a typical
conservative documentary
about like george washington's mother's
cousin we are excited to bring you
excellent edgy cutting-edge stories that
hollywood refuses to acknowledge we hope
you'll join us for the special event
tomorrow night at 7 pm eastern 4 pm
pacific at dailywire.com apple tv or
roku or
the daily wire youtube channel you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so now we get to the three
arguments against impeachment right we
did the three arguments in favor
of impeachment namely he committed a
crime secondly a challenge to the
legislative branch needs to be rebutted
by the legislative branch and third
this is just pure politics and we need
the pure politics of the situation okay
finally here's the rationales against
impeachment okay number one
and this is just true there's no time
okay realistically speaking
the impeachment is not going to have any
effect because it is already
by the calendar january 13th one week
from today
joe biden will be the president of the
united states he will not be the
president-elect he'll be the president
one week
from today the democrats are slated to
vote on impeachment today let's say they
pass it let's say they get it to the
senate
the senate is not supposed to come back
into session until january 19th
okay like the day before the
inauguration even if the senate were to
reconvene in order to hear the charges
you would then have to have an actual
defense for due process purposes
put up by the trump team that would take
longer than a week
okay so realistically speaking there
will be no impeachment before
the actual inauguration of jubaid at
which point impeachment becomes a moot
point
there's a point that's made by michael
ludick a former judge on the u.s court
of appeals for the fourth circuit
he made a convincing case it's not even
is that even constitutional to impeach a
former president some of the democrats
have been saying
you know what we should do we should
just keep the impeachment going and then
it will impeach him
after he is no longer in office and that
will bar him from running again
you know first of all that looks purely
political because at that point trump is
not even in office so what exactly are
you getting done
i guess you're passing a bill saying
that he can't run for office
again kind of but you don't need an
impeachment in order to do that
presumably you could theoretically just
pass a bill to that effect i think
okay but here's what ludic says says he
says the crux of my argument is that the
very purpose of an impeachment power is
to remove an incumbent official
that seems to me to be crystal clear and
inescapably true under the text of the
constitution
here's the relevant portion the
president vice president all civil
officers of the united states
shall be removed from office on
impeachment for and conviction of
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors the house of
representatives shall have the sole
power of impeachment
so judgment in cases of impeachment
shall not extend further than to removal
from office and disqualification to hold
and enjoy
any office of honor trust or profit
under the united states the party
convicted shall nevertheless be liable
and subject to indictment trial judgment
and punishment according to law it's
pretty obvious
that this is designed to remove the
president from office a secondary
purpose is to disqualify a president
from holding office
again ludwig says it's the impeachment
that is the authority for the
disqualification
a former president cannot be removed
from office because he is not in office
also the constitution says that if you
actually want to go after him
the constitution says specifically he
will still be liable and subject to
indictment trial judgment and punishment
according to the law democrats are
saying they can start this thing now and
they can finish it later
okay so that is just not going to happen
so realistically speaking there is no
time to get this done
just on a purely realistic timeline
level so that is a prudential argument
it is also a legal argument
okay second there is the sort of broader
narrative argument so the broader
narrative argument which is the
counterparts the argument in favor the
argument in favor is trump did a bunch
of bad stuff it resulted
broadly speaking what happened at the
capitol building the counter-veiling
narrative
is that the attempt to impeach trump is
really just the camel's nose
right that what it really is about is
not trump it's about trying to lump
trump in
with every one of his supporters and
then lump all of those supporters in
with what happened at the capitol riots
that's really what this is about so the
argument is
it goes something like this what you
guys are really trying to do
with impeachment is you're trying to
suggest that trump's
actions resulted directly in what
happened at the capitol building
and that because trump has not changed
over the past five years all of that was
foreseeable and that if you're saying
that it's 100 foreseeable that means
that everybody who voted for trump
anybody who backed anything trump ever
did
anybody who suggested that trump would
be better for the country than the
countervailing democrats anybody who
vote all 75 million people voted for
trump
all of those people should have known
and in fact did know what exactly was
going to go down at the capitol
or at least they were okay with what
down what went down at the capitol
because of course it was completely
foreseeable
because trump has not changed his folks
have not changed and this was completely
foreseeable and so what impeachment is
really about politically speaking
is about smearing every trump supporter
with the stain of what happened at the
capitol building
right that is the that is the political
argument against impeachment
okay so that argument is not true for
every democrat it's not true for
everybody who's liberal there are a lot
of democrats and liberals who say listen
the people who did that
they're responsible for what they did
trump's actions are unsustainable on a
personal level but i'm not going to
suggest that every republican knew this
was coming i'm not going to say that
every republican is responsible for this
unfortunately there's a lot of
credibility to this argument for people
who oppose the impeachment
because democrats keep saying over and
over and over again that they're lumping
all republicans together which by the
way is extraordinarily dangerous for the
country
there are many dangerous things
happening in the country right now one
is
a group of people who are disconnected
from reality doing violence at the
capitol building
and maybe threatening further violence
down the road here that's
extraordinarily dangerous
another extraordinarily dangerous thing
these are not mutually exclusive many
dangerous things can happen at once
in fact usually they do the other
extraordinarily extraordinarily
dangerous thing
is labeling half the country people who
support violence and then seeking to
quash their ability to speak freely
morally morally extirpating them right
that's a dangerous thing too
many dangerous things can happen all at
once so in favor of the argument that
what impeachment is truly about is
targeting his supporters
all you have to do is look at the
democratic side of the aisle where they
keep saying this kind of stuff over and
over and over again
so for example aoc says that
we need to rein in our media environment
the natural consequence of this
should be to reign in our media
environment we need like a truth and
reconciliation commission like south
africa
hint we don't south africa is an actual
apartheid state gang
you want to say we need a truth and
reconciliation commission in like 1966
okay you want to say we need one in 2021
i'm sorry but no but aoc says we need to
reign in the first amendment essentially
well that's lumping everybody in
together is it not
here was the estimable representative
alexander ocasio-cortez d-twitch
but what i can say is that there's
absolutely a commission that's being
discussed
but it seems to be more investigatory um
in style rather than truth and
reconciliation
and so i think that's an interesting
concept for us to explore
we're going to have to figure out
how we reign in our media environment
so that you can't just spew
disinformation and misinformation
she didn't just say that by the way she
also said that we can only begin to heal
if southern states become democratic so
it seems almost as though
this is purely political and about
targeting trump supporters here was the
estimable alexander ocasio-cortez once
again
that southern states are not red states
they are suppressed states which means
the only way
that our country is going to heal is
through the actual liberation
of southern states the actual liberation
of the poor the actual liberation
of working people from economic social
and racial oppression
that's the only way or
take for example the uh the tweets of
chris hayes of msnbc
so chris hayes tweeted out in the
aftermath of all this a picture of trump
with amy coney barrett quote
wonder if emmy coney barrett has
pictures like this framed and up in her
house or not
it's a picture of coney barrett with
trump so the idea is
any remote association with trump means
that you are in favor of the capital
riots
right everyone is guilty every single
person is guilty amy coney barrett is
guilty she's just a judge
and now she's going to be appointed to
she's on the supreme court
put there by trump that means everything
trump ever did anything he ever touched
anybody who's in favor of those things
is bad
right so the case against impeachment
here is that when you're impeaching
trump what you're really doing is you're
setting the predicate for an argument
which is that again
not only is he responsible for
quote-unquote incitement but everybody
who voted for him knew
that this sort of stuff was going to
culminate in what happened at the
capitol building which is an absurd
contention
it's an absurd contention okay but that
is you know
what much of the democratic left is
pushing you have nicole hannah jones
saying the same thing right she
basically just says well you know those
capital rioters essentially they're just
reflecting the generalized republican
point of view
right because she believes that all
republicans are basically racist who are
seeking to
impose white supremacy on the nation
here was the the excretable awful
terrible
liar nicole hannah jones the racial
divide has always been
uh since the american revolution when
the british exploited the racial divide
against the colonists the sharpest tool
in the arsenal we have kind of a
almost a primal um
reaction to the stoking of that racial
divide and it never benefits low-income
white americans it only benefits the
elite and we saw what happened with that
this past week oh so it's about
benefiting the elites it's all part of
the same kind of
broad rit republican evil conservative
coalition
another point in favor of this idea that
impeachment truly is about going after
trump's supporters and this has become a
big talking point
on uh on the on the right and given the
reaction of the left
there's some credibility to it it is not
completely specious okay forbes
magazine put out an article today
suggesting quote a truth reckoning why
we're holding those who lied for trump
accountable this is randall lane
of forbes staff he says the insurrection
was rooted in lies
he says from day one at the white house
up has been down yes has been no failure
has been success
he cites sean spicer and kellyanne
conway he says as american democracy
rebounds we need to return to a standard
of truth when it comes to how the
government communicates with the
governed the easiest way to do that from
where i said is to create repercussions
for those who don't follow the civic
norms
trump's lawyers lie gleefully to the
present public those lies magically
almost never made it into recent
arguments
so what's the parallel and the dark arts
of communication simple don't let the
chronic liars cash in on their
dishonesty
press secretaries like joe lockhart ari
fleisher and jay carney who left the
white house with their reputations in
various stages of intact
made millions taking their skills and
credibility to corporate america trump's
liars don't merit the same golden
parachute let it be known to the
business world
hire any of trump's fellow fabulous
above and forbes will assume
everything your company or firm talks
about is lie so jay carney is now the
standard of truth
according to forbes so we're going to ex
we are going to excise everyone who
worked with trump not just trump
everybody who worked with trump
is going to be excised meanwhile youtube
is cracking down
on trump according to the washington
post
youtube has now suspended trump from
uploading new videos to his official
account for at least a week
joining twitter and facebook and
shutting the president out of his
account due to concerns his posts will
incite violence
right so again they've not made the case
that his post did incite the violence in
any sort of legal fashion
doesn't matter they're just gonna take
what trump says and they're just gonna
remove it
okay and everybody on the right is going
okay so you can now make the argument
that anything that i say is going to
incite violence as well and just remove
that
willy-nilly so when the left uses this
as a tool as a political tool to club
into submission
all the people on the right then i don't
think the right
is wrong to look sideways and
impeachment and say i don't i'm doubting
some of your motives here
i'm doubting some of your motives which
brings us to the third case against
impeachment
okay the third case against impeachment
goes something like this
if you wish for the country to reunite
then democrats are going to have to
show some magnanimity in victory here
and it would be magnanimity right
they're going to have to say
listen we're a week out trump got what
he deserved he got
not elected if we have criminal charges
to bring we'll bring them against the
people who actually violated the law
and in order to move forward here we're
going to recognize there are a lot of
republicans across the other side of the
aisle who disagree with us on
impeachment but
who stood with us in the face of threats
to democracy right mike pence stood with
us mitch mcconnell stood with us this is
not a right left divide
this is an american versus anti-american
divide first of all
they said that i think there might
actually be more import more support for
impeachment it's the fact they're
lumping every
everybody together that's creating the
backlash however
if they continue along these lines what
they're actually going to create is a
backlash in favor of trump right this is
another of the arguments against
impeachment
it creates a backlash in favor of trump
trump is already stoking that he says
this is a continuation of the witch hunt
here's president trump
on the impeachment it's really a
continuation
of the greatest witch hunt in the
history of politics
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous
this impeachment is causing tremendous
anger
and you're doing it and it's really a
terrible thing that they're doing
okay so uh you know that is going to
start generating more and more support
the more that the left continues to lump
in everybody
with trump tim scott uh has has put out
a tweet
thread suggesting why he is not in favor
of impeachment
intuitive president trump has eight days
left in his term and has promised a
smooth and peaceful transition of power
the democrat led impeachment talks
happening in the house right now flying
direct opposition to what president
elect obiden has been calling for all
year an impeachment vote will only lead
to more hate and a deeply fractured
nation i oppose impeaching
president trump a lot of people saying
well you know if he deserves impeachment
then
like you're talking unity but nobody was
talking unity last week
that's true but that's the point about
unity somebody's going to actually have
to step forward and be the uniting
figure
biden posed himself as that person so at
a certain point here he is going to have
to step forward and he is going to have
to
stump in favor of unity now if trump had
been isolated here
if trump had actually committed criminal
conduct like actual
prosecutable criminal conduct i think
this would be a lot easier but when
people on the left say uh
you're calling for unity now you weren't
calling for unity five minutes ago well
some of us were actually kind of calling
for unity for a long time here
at least around fundamental american
principles and the left was rejecting a
lot of those fundamental american
principles we were saying how about we
unify around violence is bad
and a lot of folks on left well it
depends on what the violence is for
and some of us are like you know what if
we unified around the principle that
claims require evidence and left was
like well
it depends which claims so
here's the thing about unity unity
requires some sacrifice on both sides
okay unity requires for the right to
recognize baseline truths
like some of the truths i've said
violence is bad at the capital i think
most republicans
agree with that that that
unevidenced allegations are not
sufficient to support action
i think that the right should agree with
that in fact there have been some of us
who've been saying this since the day of
the election when president trump
declared himself the victor
i said immediately he does not have the
evidence to back that i got a lot of
flack from the right for saying that
okay but we should all agree on that on
the left the same agreement has to take
place
what does that have to do with
impeachment well it means
that you have to make clear the grounds
of the impeachment
you can't lump people together if you're
if you're going to pursue it
and again you have to explain why it's
necessary to do this when it's not going
to get done before the election
why this isn't a political tool because
it looks like a political tool
that's what it looks like especially in
the midst of this massive
backlash against people of the right on
tech platforms
in the midst of removing parlor from
from amazon web services
and all the rest so what exactly would
be the proper response here you know
some people are like okay well what's
the
you're saying no impeachment what's the
proper response well
it seems to me number one that the the
generalized sort of republican
leadership position which is
republicans should vote whatever their
conscience decides is not a bad
imp impulse i think that you know when
republicans do that i'm generally in
favor
i don't think that you need a lot of
top-down direction inside republican
circles i think it sort of cuts against
the nature of conservatism
so you know mitch mcconnell not rallying
support again against the cause again
because i think that
there's some legitimate claims here uh i
don't think that that's bad
i don't agree with him if he is in favor
of impeachment but i think the idea that
republicans have to decide based on
their own consciences where they stand
on this thing
and they have to weigh all of the
varying sort of narratives here uh
is good people can come to different
conclusions as i guess what i am saying
here i know
shocking conclusion but what do i think
is the actual proper response i think
the actual proper response is what brian
fitzpatrick
the republican congressperson from
pennsylvania suggested
he was moving for an act of
congressional censure kevin mccarthy the
house majority the house minority leader
was also
pushing for congressional censure of
president trump's behavior that seems
proper to me because again the president
did not commit a crime but that doesn't
mean you can't censure him for his
language
you can't censor him for his actions
that seems perfectly appropriate
it has nothing to do with the
impeachment process it can get done
before the election democrats have
rejected that out of hand because they
want something obviously
more dramatic and again a lot of this is
about holding over the heads
of conservatives the threat that if you
ever say anything in the future we just
say well you voted for trump and trump
resulted in the capital riot
right that's going to be the line from
democrats from here it's the end of time
republicans know it which is why so many
republicans are knee-jerk against what
democrats are trying
to do here okay meanwhile one of the
things that is is forwarding
a lot of the ire on the right is again
that that vast wave that you are seeing
from the left you're trying to lump
everybody together and suggest that
every trump supporter do this was coming
and that if you voted for trump this was
part of the bargain was riots at the
capitol building which is just not true
okay again if the policing had been
sufficient that would not have been
the outcome there a lot of people had
gotten arrested in any case
the the next move is the social media
attempts
to shut down all dissenting speech and
this is the thing that's scaring the
hell out of everybody right we've seen
youtube and twitter and facebook all
move in coordination
to censor the president of the united
states you don't have to like what trump
says i've been condemning it
consistently
that does not mean that the best move
here is for social media to literally
shut off the tap
for the president of the united states
that the social media companies
should not be held responsible for
people posting content that is then
misused
by fringe people to go do violence
because that literally justifies the
removal of any controversial speech ever
ever as somebody who's in the business
of political speech
it is not difficult to find for people
who have very very large audiences nut
jobs will misuse their words to go do
bad things
this is true right left and center the
left doesn't seem to care about it
though because they know they're not
going to be held accountable for it so
if they hold the right accountable for
it
this means they can also de-platform
sites they don't particularly like so
amazon web services takes down parlor
and then amazon web services put out a
brief
pointing out all of the bad things that
have been said on parlor all the violent
things that have been said on parlor
okay just a note
twitter has exactly that same kind of
content there's plenty
of evil terrible content on twitter that
they're remiss
in taking down the same thing is true on
facebook so sheryl sandberg on facebook
she said
you know these riots were not organized
on our platform then she has as far as
we know
i'm not sure how far that is i would
assume that many of the people who i
mean stop the steal was still on
facebook up until about 24 hours ago
so i assumed that a lot of the activity
actually was coordinated in places like
facebook because facebook is a hell of a
lot bigger than parlor is
and facebook has billions of users
parlor at its height had like three and
a half million users
anyway here is sheryl sandberg of
facebook saying no we've never no
nothing bad has ever happened at
facebook
sure well we know this was organized
online we know that um we again took
down q anon proud boys stop this deal
anything that was talking about possible
violence last week
our enforcement's never perfect so i'm
sure there were still
things on facebook i think these events
were largely
organized on platforms that don't have
our
abilities to stop hate and don't have
our standards and don't have our
transparency
but certainly to this day we are working
to find any
single mention that might be exist and
making sure we get it down as quickly as
possible
okay so um she can't be sure also um
just a note there were mass riots in the
summer how many of those do you think
were organized on parlor
how many really can't imagine tons of
them
i'm not sure black lives matter was
using parlor as its organizing weapon
if the idea is that platforms are now
responsible for people misusing the
platforms
that's the i mean honestly that's a
bigger argument against free speech
and that is the argument that people on
left are now making they're basically
saying free speech is inherently
dangerous because free speech can be
misused
yes that's true free speech can be
misused and you know it's even worse the
government cracking down on free speech
or
in the cultural sphere social media
which was supposed to be the public
square
cracking down on free speech
particularly from apps that
that centralize conservatives right that
is a very very dangerous thing because
any
there is no consistent standard this is
the point that i'm making it is not
that parlor did an amazing job of
policing its content i don't think
anybody's making that argument
the point is that there is no consistent
standard being applied
it is not as though if a platform allows
violent rhetoric
to fester that this is what causes
amazon web services to take down
the the app twitter's still up plenty of
gross stuff on twitter
okay it is that when when it is located
in
in quote unquote conservative or trump
supporting circles and it seems to
centralize those supporters in one place
then it's it's super bad and becomes
targeted by the entire tech bro
infrastructure there's a reason for that
the tech companies are dominated by the
left they're dominated by it and they do
not have
overall a great commitment to free
speech and the most ironic tweet of
yesterday was getting passed around an
awful lot
was this tweet from twitter public
policy so according to twitter public
policy ahead of the ugandan elections
they said they were hearing reports that
the internet service providers were
being ordered to block social media and
messaging apps
they said we strongly condemn internet
shutdowns they're hugely harmful violate
basic human rights and the principles
of the open internet and then they added
access to information and freedom of
expression including the public
conversations on twitter
is never more important than during
democratic processes particularly
elections
oh twitter oh twitter you stupid stupid
app
i was f i mean i'm old enough to
remember because i'm more than six
months old
when you for a month suspended the new
york post and the run up to an election
because you didn't like that they
printed a true story about joe biden's
son's laptop
and so do i trust you guys being a free
speech outlet
no i do not now there are a lot of
people who are saying well you know you
have a lot of followers and 100 i have a
lot of followers on twitter does that
mean i trust them
to interpret standards properly no i do
not
i have a huge following on facebook do i
trust that facebook is going to be
consistent in its standards
or that they are not going to morph
their standards in order to excise
conservative speech
no i do not and i'm not sure why you
would either considering they have been
utterly
opaque as to what their standards are
they've not been clear about what those
standards ought to be
they've not been clear with people when
their accounts get taken down why those
accounts are getting taken down
this is scary stuff it should frighten
people many bad things can be happening
at once
many bad things okay and among those bad
things is indeed the domination of
social media which is effectually our
public square
by the left by the way if you think that
it is any sort of uh if you think that
there's any sort of coincidence
that facebook and twitter and youtube
all started doing the bidding of
democratic politicians the minute that
joe biden won
uh uh you're you're a fool it is it is
purely obvious and i know this from from
i have many
friends who work inside various tech
companies it is perfectly clear
that the minute that joe biden won and
particularly the minute that the
republicans
lost the georgia senate races that the
movement inside tech
was going to be to please democratic
senators who are putting overt pressure
on the tech bros to crack down on speech
they don't like that is a
threat to the republic so when we're
talking about threats to the republic
people storming the capital building yes
that is a threat to the republic it also
happened to be
a couple of hundred people who are
violent and evil and ought to be put in
jail
when you're talking about institutions
that govern
the lives and free speech patterns of
hundreds of millions of people
deciding arbitrarily what their free
speech standards are
and doing so on the basis of politics
and pressure from democratic actors
democratic senators claiming that
they're going gonna break up companies
unless those companies do what they want
that seems to me like a threat to the
republic as well that is a super
dangerous thing
and it is not a coincidence that so many
members of the incoming biden
administration
are tech bros according to the daily
caller at least 14 people
who biden had picked to serve either in
his administration or advise his
transition
have worked for big tech firms that
crack down earlier this week on
president trump apple's top lobbyist was
the chief advisor to the biden
transition
a former facebook executive will serve
as staff director in the biden white
house a former twitter executive will
serve as
chief spokesperson for the national
security council under biden
current and former executives at those
firms and two others google and amazon
fill out other positions in the incoming
biden administration
by the way if you ever look at the
donations of tech companies i was
looking this up
the other day donations by employees of
the various tech companies
there is not a major tech company in the
united states outside of qualcomm so far
as i'm aware that does not donate
in extraordinary proportions to
democrats there's a reason that susan
rice
right the obama admin staffer who lies
in the american public about benghazi
now the
the new coming domestic policy advisor
for no reason
in the biden administration she was on
the netflix board
okay as of 2018 99.6
of all donations from netflix employees
went to democrats
adobe 93 of all donations
in 2018 went to democrats in 2016 it was
this is according to cnbc ibm went 90 10
for democrats
salesforce went 89-11 for democrats
google went 88-12 for democrats
microsoft went 85-15 for democrats apple
went 84-16
for democrats paypal went 84-16 for
democrats cisco
went 80-20 for democrats and amazon went
77-23 for democrats how about facebook
77-23
for democrats of course cheryl sandberg
previously worked for
larry summers who was the treasury
secretary under bill clinton
intel by the way also 68 32 democrats
the tech companies are dominated by the
left it's perfectly obvious so why would
you trust them to have any sort of
consistent standard when they won't be
transparent about the standards
and what we are what we are watching and
and all of this doesn't happen in vacuum
right
when bad thing happens on the right very
often there's a corollary on the left
and vice versa and vice versa
right there is a there is a mishmash of
bad information and i will tell you the
kind of lie that is the worst right now
because there are lots of lies all over
the place there are lies told about this
election
by president trump there are lies told
about this election
by the media the worst kind of lie is
the double standard
the worst kind of lies the double
standard because it assumes that the
person who is of your political ilk
ought to be treated with absolute
reverence and the person on the other
side
for doing the exact same thing ought to
be torn down to the ground
it is double standards that undermine
the republic more than any other kind of
lie there are lots of lies out there
misinformation is nothing new
it's the double standard in american
politics where you hold somebody to a
different standard
than you would if they were a member of
the other party that is the real danger
to the republic right now
and one that is applied formally in
terms of policy at both the governmental
and non-governmental level
levels inside major tech corporations
that control how you speak and how you
think and how you
communicate with others we're at an
extraordinarily dangerous moment
in the life of the american republic
alrighty we'll be back here tomorrow
with much much more the outcome
of the house impeachment vote which is
pretty much for which is pretty much a
foregone conclusion
we'll also get to how the senate is
going to respond i am sure
in the meantime stick around for our
other shows as well as the second
hour of the benchmark show coming a
little bit later today i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show